[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le 21 mai 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les principaux titres
selon le syndicat snuipp-fsu sentent 14
% des professeurs des écoles estiment
que l'organisation des rythmes scolaires
a un impact négatif sur les élèves mais
à trappes c'est en raison des
contraintes budgétaires que de nouveaux
ajustements pourraient se mettre en
place les enseignants se mobilisent et
des personnalités du sport du spectacle
et de la recherche présente au club de
tennis des pyramides à port marly une
opération de soutien à l'association et
blinoise imagine fort marco qui collecte
des fonds pour aider la recherche contre
le cancer des enfants et puis la
parentalité au coeur du spectacle nos
chers enfants présenté le 26 mai à la
salle jacques brel à montigny le
bretonneux auteurs comédiens notamment
invité du journal pour en parler tout à
l'heure alors que le comité de suivi des
rythmes scolaires de la ville de trappes
se réunissait mardi soir les enseignants
de la commune avait choisi de distribuer
des tracts pour informer les parents de
leur mécontentement si les horaires
venait à changer ce serait tout
simplement la troisième fois en trois
ans mélanie poquet elodie moines rentrée
scolaire 2014 le planning des élèves
trappistes ressembler à ça septembre
il pourrait être à nouveau transformé
c'est ce qu'envisage le comité de suivi
des rythmes scolaires de la commune donc
si vous voulez
le scénario proposé une alternance
d'horaires selon les écoles une école
finissent à 15 heures le lendemain 16
heures 30
et comme ça on alternait on pouvait il
pouvait utiliser les animateurs sur
plusieurs écoles en fonction des stars
seulement ça pose énormément de
problèmes par rapport
à l'enseignement sur le plan scolaire on
ne souhaite pas que ce soit le
périscolaire qui prime sur le scolaire
sur les temps d'enseignement des élèves
donc c'est le scolaire qui doit passer
avant tout cette solution permettrait de
réduire le nombre d'animateurs assurant
le périscolaire c'est un problème
d'effectif de 15h30 à 16h30 qui est au
coeur de la réforme
mais cette solution entraînerait aussi
des journées de six heures pour les
élèves alors que les rythmes mis en
place par l'éducation nationale impose
des journées de 5h30 maximum la ville de
trappes connaîtrait à l'insa troisième
réforme en trois rentrées scolaires qui
m'inquiète c'est que c'est que on a mis
un rythme enfin nous imposer un jeu
modifications rythme en course était
nationale a priori donc voilà on
encaisse un petit peu même si on le veut
pas et
ça se met en place de façon très très
difficile l'an dernier finalement on
arrive à trouver à semer équilibre cette
année avec des journées qui se
ressentent tout c'était déjà pas mal mon
maternelle dans tous les cas et et là
bas on met tout en l'air on fait tout
sauter parce que manque de rance et du
manque de manque de personnel qualifié
manque de moyens monde 2 mais bon on
parle de on parle de moyens on parle de
financement on parle pas beaucoup
d'enfants l'histoire les enseignants
mobilisés soit resté aux horaires déjà
en place
la mairie fixera définitivement les
conditions de la réforme la semaine
prochaine lors d'une dernière réunion et
ne souhaite pas s'exprimer pour
l'instant
dans une quinzaine de jours se déroulera
à saint quentin en yvelines le festival
alternatiba ce sera sur la commune de la
verrière de jours pour alerter pour
mobiliser réfléchir échanger sur le
changement climatique notamment il
s'agira de la première édition de ce
rendez-vous en ile-de-france le
programme a été dévoilé ce matin mélanie
poker william l le programme vient
d'être dévoilée les 6 et 7 juin
prochains la ville de la verrière
accueillera pendant deux jours le
village dit alternatif du festival
alternatiba saint quentin en yvelines
au programme exposants ateliers
conférences mais aussi concerts
représentations théâtre et lecture de
contes à destination des enfants
c'est un moment festif et un festival
qui a pour objectif de montrer des
alternatives et des alternatives
positives aux changements climatiques
parce que neuf constats d'origine et que
on parle trop souvent de manière
négative les changements climatiques
c'est toujours une contrainte est en
fait l'objectif c'est vraiment de
montrer que ça peut être aussi une
opportunité ça peut être une opportunité
de montrer des choses positives aux gens
de voir d'autres façons de vivre plus en
accord avec la nature
héritier du festival alternativa de
bayonne du 6 octobre 2013
celui de saint quentin en yvelines sera
le premier organisé en ile de france
le village des alternatives se trouvera
au tour d'ali parquet de la salle du
scarabée grâce à un financement
participatif concluant le festival a
récolté plus de 17000 euros
l'accès au village sera gratuit
l'entrée par le festival peut se faire
d'à peu près toutes les rues de la
verrière donc c'est vraiment l'idée
d'utiliser les rues de créer un village
au premier sens d'un village c'est à
dire qu'un village est évidemment un
mieux
ouvert à tous à tous où tout a toujours
qui tous les gens qui passent et qui ont
envie de s'arrêter pour assurer le
fonctionnement ainsi qu'un bon accueil
des cinq mille visiteurs attendus
le collectif recherche des bénévoles et
si le village les couper en quartiers
thématiques ne durera que le temps d'un
week-end le collectif espère que les
idées de viendront durable sept matches
pour des enfants sans cancer c'est le
mot d'ordre hier c'était le mot d'ordre
au club des pyramides de port marly le
site était ouvert exceptionnellement au
profit d'une association imagine fort
margot association qui soutient la
recherche médicale qui aident au
bien-être également des jeunes malades
plusieurs artistes et sportifs étaient
présents yolaine torres des williams
elle pour les images set et match pour
des enfants son cancer c'est le nom de
l'événement organisé hier par
l'association et vloaz imagine fort
margot au club des pyramides de port
marly les visiteurs ont pu profiter
d'animations diverses
objectif collecter des fonds pour le
bien-être des enfants dans les hôpitaux
quand ils sont à l'hôpital or ce type de
maladie s'est longtemps c'est pour des
traitements qui sont toxiques agressif
et si on peut appeler améliorer leur
quotidien est bien fait à leurs foyers
pour les enfants et pour les parents des
jouets des tablettes ou encore du
mobilier c'est ce qui ressort de leur
enquête auprès des hôpitaux pour
connaître leurs besoins
hier chacun ya mis du sien des enfants
des magiciens de danseurs ainsi que des
personnalités au grand coeur parmi elles
nicolas mahut joueur de tennis
professionnel en pleine préparation pour
roland-garros il a fait un crochet dans
les yvelines pour la bonne cause ouais
les enfants malades je me sens concernée
et moi même je parraine déjà une
association qui s'appelle rêve
justement pour réaliser des rêves
d'enfants malades donc tout de suite
j'ai été sensible à cette invitation et
pour moi ça me semblait ça me semblait
normal d'essayer de participer à ce
genre d'événement margot la fille de
patricia est décédé à l'âge de 13 ans
d'une tumeur au cerveau
c'est lorsqu'elle se battait contre la
maladie que sa mère s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait très peu de traitements adaptés
aux enfants dans des cas de cancers
difficile on a décidé lorsque
malheureusement à nous acquitter de
monter cette association pour vraiment
essayé de développer la recherche sur le
cancer des enfants des nouveaux
traitements spécifiques pour les enfants
et en même temps pour sensibiliser à
cette cause parce qu'on ne sait pas que
les enfants des concerts et c'est quand
même de 1500 enfants en france qui
chaque année sont diagnostiqués et sa
cinquième heure
des chiffres qui en disent long et qui
font du concert la première cause de
décès des enfants par maladie en trois
ans l'association a versé un million
trois cent mille euros à la recherche de
traitements spécifiques pour les enfants
atteints de cancer rendez vous le 27
septembre prochain au parc de saint
cloud pour la quatrième édition de la
course en font son cancer une pluie de
stars également ce mardi sur le golf de
la queue-lez-yvelines cinquante sportifs
de haut niveau se sont affrontés sur le
green pour la 23e édition du tibre est
qu ils ont ensuite participé à une
soirée d'enchères caritative au profit
de l'association sos gazelle 16000 euros
ont été collectés
en parallèle de cette manifestation les
athlètes ont également animé des
ateliers pendant toute la journée des
élèves des lycées professionnels mathis
et blériot de trappes et des étudiants
de versailles ont notamment pratiqué la
boxe avec jean marc mormeck le boxeur
qui était au micro de michael et demi
d'eau c'est toujours important on est
avec des jeunes en les encadrant
et puis on fait des activités que l'on
aime et puis cela c'est une détente
aussi c'est le moment c'est le
rencontrer les autres sportifs et
d'échangé ebs et brouillent tous bien au
gazon c'est la volonté qui met justement
à pouvoir en faire le l'exercice à
comprendre le sport et puis l'envi
qu'ils ont c'est une super idée
initiative et j'espère que ça va encore
continuer encore longtemps et que ces
jeunes et puis il y en aura encore de
plus en plus les invités de cette
édition ils sont trois âges à blanzat
bonsoir vous êtes auteur de la compagnie
au pied de la lettre
comédienne également comédien leur en
suis rebond soit et marie noëlle tarot
bienvenue en plateau également outre
adjointe à montigny le bretonneux en
charge de la solidarité de l'action
sociale on va évoquer et cette pièce qui
sera jouée le 26 mai à la salle jacques
brel à montigny le bretonneux par votre
compagnie une pièce présentée avec
notamment le ccs le centre d'action
sociale de la commune de montigny le nom
de cette pièce nos chers enfants
il y est question du bonheur mais aussi
de la difficulté d'être parent jafza
vous êtes à l'origine de cette création
expliqué nous un peu la démarche vous
vouliez montrer la diversité dans la
façon d'approcher la parentalité
justement oui tout à fait en fait comme
souvent les oeuvres sont
autobiographiques ça vient de mon
histoire de mon histoire d'enfant avec
mes parents et j'ai eu envie de
collecter des témoignages d'aller voir
qu'est ce qui se passe ailleurs chez
d'autres parents et donc comme ça j'ai
collecté des témoignages
j'ai fait cette mosaïque de personnages
différents de d'émotions différentes de
points de vue différents de deux ans on
travaille deux ans dans qui a tant fait
tendues oui tout à fait deux ans
d'enquêté et si moi l'écriture six mois
d'écriture on va regarder un premier
extrait de cette pièce il y est question
de l'eau de l'autorité pardon de la
fessée moi je l'envoie au coin c'est
basique c'est le coin sans doudou santé
tine et tu ne parles pas eu part sur le
fait jamais
freeze et 4 sommes six mois je fais pas
commun parce que je trouve comme un mal
de progresser parfois on ne mesure pas
lorsqu'on donne alors si on me donne
déficit trop fort ça peut faire mal
moi je ne devrais pas beaucoup parce que
pour moi c'est pas nécessaire de donner
des fessées
voilà des questions que se pose
forcément les parents on va évoquer le
travail de comédien la place du ccs
aussi au milieu de tout ça de cette
programmation
tout d'abord on l'a entendu il ya une
petite fille c'est un peu le fil rouge
dans sa pièce tout à fait c'est le fil
rouge de l'histoire d'une petite fille
qui évoque elle quand elle sera grande
sa version de la maman qu'elle sera
quand elle sera grande et elle revient
comme ça de temps en temps tout au long
du spectacle pour donner son point de
vue par rapport à ce que disent les
parents tout au long du spectacle pour
autant c'est un spectacle qui s'adresse
aux paroles toutefois là on pourrait
très bien pour être très clair et je
n'ai pas précisé c'est également en
entrée libre
oui voilà la pièce marie noëlle tarot
comment vous vous êtes associé avec la
ville sur ce sur ce projet cette
présentation justement à la basse et la
maison de la famille qui prend une
partie de toutes les activités que nous
essayons de développer auprès des
parents des grands parents puisque nous
avons voulu une thématique très large et
non pas être sûrs ou une école des
parents ou un lieu spécifique par an
nous avons toujours voulu élargir et
donc c'est pour ça que nous nous avons
fait ça s'appelle la maison de la
famille et effectivement c'est la
responsable de ce cette action qui par
le biais de laurent savard que nous
connaissons depuis longtemps et qui
travaille aussi avec nous lorsque nous
faisons nos actions sur le handicap qui
a pu découvrir cette pièce de théâtre et
qui nous en a parlé et nous a convaincus
que c'était un élément très important de
pouvoir présenter ses différentes
visions de la famille et des différentes
réactions des parents des enfants par
rapport à
le quotidien qui existe un petit côté
pédagogique apporter des réponses d'une
autre façon à travers un spectacle cette
fois ci voilà c'est enfin pédagogique je
sais pas si on est là pour faire de la
pédagogie auprès des parents les parents
ils ont la possibilité eux-mêmes de
réfléchir et d'évoluer dans leur façon
de s'occuper de leurs enfants je crois
que c'est à chacun de découvrir et donc
effectivement de présenter une palette
comme un patchwork que disait tout à qui
a été expliqué tout à l'heure je pense
que c'est un bon moyen de peut-être
pouvoir effectivement accroché se dire
ah tiens j'ai fait ça j'aurais peut-être
pas du tout ça si j'ai fait ça c'est
bien
je vais j'ai continué dans cet axe là
qu'est ce que justement des printemps
paul est un petit peu les parents de
leur faire des propositions je pense que
ça peut faire réfléchir ça peut évoquer
effectivement des souvenirs ou ou des
idées tient sa g aurais pas pensé je
pourrais faire comme ça comme le conseil
familial par exemple que je joue
laurence rires oui ça peut ça peut
interpeller effectivement on a eu pas
mal de retours de la part des
spectateurs d'ailleurs des choses
inattendues assez émouvante d'ailleurs
pour les comédiens justement leur
inspire le sujet déjà alors les 100 mg
qui vous parle
oui j'avais vu en fait j'avais vu le par
hasard la lecture de nos chers enfants
j'étais pas encore sur le vote sur le
projet j'avais adoré donc on avait
discuté après avec jade avec rémy avec
les autres comédiens et j'avais trouvé
ça formidable et puis m'ont rappelé un
mois après en disant voilà on a quelques
dates est ce que ça te dit oui j'ai
foncé j'ai passé 2 les essais et ça
s'est bien passé et moi étant parents
étant père de famille de deux jeunes
enfants
fatalement samassa ma ça m'a plu tout de
suite et de jouer des personnages
différents complètement différent de moi
mais voilà qui qui qui vont plaire qui
vont qui vont parler à tout le monde
quelque part c'était c'était vraiment
cessé vraiment jouer ici parce que vous
l'avez dit des personnages vous êtes
quatre sur scène il ya une trentaine de
personnages en temps on est 8
ils ont dit oui c'est schizophrénique
c'est en même temps c'est c'est
passionnant parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'il ya pas une seule parentalité il
n'ya pas il ya ce que
disait jean renoir dans la règle du jeu
le grand problème de ce monde sait que
tout le monde a ses raisons et là tout
le monde a ses raisons voilà tout le
tool et où chaque chaque personnage a
ses raisons se défend voilà après ça il
peut y avoir des choses drôles et sont
beaucoup moins drôle mais c'est voilà
c'est ça qui est vraiment passionnant et
voilà c'est le mystère de l'au delà de
la création d'un de d'enfants et comment
les éduquer ces voix là c'est mais aucun
jugement
d'aucuns à travers toute la pièce n'ont
aucun jugement ricains aucun chaque
vraiment chacun a ses raisons
il ya en tant que médian du juge pas une
seule fois et les personnages on les
joue avec énormément plaisir et on les
écoute là on répétait dernièrement moi
je réécoutais le texte donc voila et je
me rendais compte de deux choses très
justes
chez les ch et chaque personnage
vraiment de choses il ya des âges
différents il ya une sexualité
différente et c'est parce que les
préoccupations contemporaines cette
hausse y est abordé à travers cette
pièce la gestation pour autrui par
exemple encore le mariage pour tous on
écoute un nouvel extrait de cette pièce
être en couple avec une femme c'est
compliqué enfin je veux dire dans la
façon de faire un enfant bien sûr on a
d'abord cherché un couple 2 mais très
vite on s'est dit il va falloir partager
un enfant à 4 il va falloir partager
leurs opinions
leur éducation leurs convictions
politiques et religieuses jusqu'à la fin
de notre vie on avait vraiment envie de
ça avec mon mari on avait décidé d'avoir
un enfant
au bout d'un homme a commencé à
s'inquiéter
du coup on a fait les examens en troll
petit à petit on a mis le doigt dans
l'engrenage de la procréation
médicalement assistée et là on te prend
la main
le bras le corps en deux mois le désir
d'enfant se transforme en obsession
d'enfants gpa mariage pour tous son
homosexualité il n'y a pas de tabou donc
ce que vous avez souhaité aborder
d'options handicap la mort aussi ça a
été un sujet assez difficile je ne
voulais pas l'aborder au début et puis
j'ai tout mis des barrières autour des
bleus au début c'était un sujet que je
voulais pas aborder ça me faisait un peu
peur
et puis finalement en parlant autour de
moi des amis m'ont convaincu monde ici
si tu parle de ce sujet il faut aussi
aborder ça parce que ça existe ça ça
fait partie de la vie et donc gg
interhumaine une personne qui a qu'a
perdu un enfant dans un accident de
voiture c'était une interview assez
difficile d'ailleurs c'était vraiment
pas simple et puis finalement je suis
content d'eux que ce témoignage existe
dans le spectacle parce que
effectivement il faut il faut en parler
il faut l'aborder ça existe pour le
travail que vous menez avec la
municipalité toujours dans l'optique
justement de ces structures
c'était important aussi de s'adresser à
tout le monde que personne ne soit exclu
et que tous les thèmes tout le monde une
fois de plus pu s'y retrouver tout à
fait c'est enfin c'est depuis le début
la création de cette maison de la
famille c'est vraiment l'objectif que
tout le monde puisse se retrouver et
chacun a sa vie et chacun essaye je vais
dire de s'en sortir le mieux possible
en réponse aux attentes des enfants est
effectivement pour certaines familles le
deuil c'est quand même quelque chose qui
est vraiment très très difficile et
peut-être que ça apportera un petit peu
de soulagement à une famille à qui ça a
pu arriver parce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très douloureux
on leur donne la date de la
représentation 26 mai 20h30 salle
jacques brel
le bretonneux ya déjà eu des
représentations dans d'autres régions
paravent est ce que c'est une pièce qui
va évoluer aussi
oui on a d'autres dates en attente et
oui mais sur la conception aussi est-ce
que vous évoluez dans l'est dans les
dialogues dans les scènes n'ont par
contre le spectacle est structuré de
cette manière donc ça ça ne va pas
changer par contre on actualise
régulièrement parce que par exemple
quand j'ai interviewé des personnes qui
me parlait du mariage pour tous c'était
avant que la loi passe donc la loi est
passée du coup j'ai dû actualisé
certains témoignages
voilà je voulais préciser aussi il ya
effectivement des témoignages assez
triste c'est dramatique mais il ya
énormément d'humour mais aussi oui bien
sûr oui on est revenue sur des thèmes
qui était la parentalité et il ya des
moments de toute façon très drôle
il ya même eu même si c'est des des
ennuis à la base mais il ya des choses
très très drôle
il ya des parents dépassés par le
changement des coûts et voilà le
justement quels sont vos difficultés
avec vos enfants c'est notre question du
jour micro trottoir et ont conclu ce
plateau juste après c'est pas évident
tout organisé il faut toujours être à
leur écoute plane organisation interne
essentiellement des difficultés
d'orientation
voir vers kehl vers quel métier se
diriger nous avons c'est vrai que c'est
difficile mais sinon pour l'instant moi
les miens sont en bas âge d'accord
crèche puis il ya de n'être donc pour
l'instant ça se passe bien
non j'ai pas eu de soucis plus important
que sa mise à part une séparation qui a
fait un peu difficulté on va dire au
niveau de l' équilibre des enfants
maintenant que ça s'est bien passé
c'est toutes les questions un autre
époque on parlait pas trop de sexualité
mais quand les enfants en parlait
fallait aller soit vers les spécialistes
soit le recours aux livres soit entre
quoi en tant que comédien vous vous êtes
nos rites votre expérience parce que le
monsieur je n'ai pas eu le choix ici à
part une séparation par le site
séparation et on en part abandonné dans
l'eau dans le spectacle fatalement et on
se rend compte que la séparation est
rentré dans les moeurs
maintenant voilà des évidemment un
couple de grands parents en parlent avec
les c'est très très drôle c'est vraiment
un couple de grands-parents qui dure je
sais pas peut-être dix minutes je sais
pas vous massez c'est moi je suis pas
dedans mais je trouve ça formidable
c'est
nos chers enfants salle jacques brel
montigny-le-bretonneux le 26 mai à 20h30
merci à tous les trois on est repassé en
plateau la suite du journal avec cette
opération originale après une série
d'ateliers dirigés par un comédien des
élèves de 6e de 5e de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont retrouvés au prisme à
elancourt pour un concours de menteries
il s'agissait de raconter une histoire
incroyable mais crédible un savant
mélange de mensonges et de vérité comme
nous l'expliqué lionel torrès une
histoire a priori banale racontait sur
scène devant un public cette semaine des
collégiens yvelinois ont tenté de
remporter le concours de la meilleure
menteries un concours organisé pour la
deuxième année consécutive aux prises
mail en cours l'idc voilà c'est de
travailler le genre de la menterie qui
est pas du mensonge qui est un mensonge
mais en dentelle un petit peu qui est
qu'il ya plus de finesse que le mensonge
qui donc parts de quelque chose de
vraisemblable et qui finit par basculer
sur quelque chose d'invraisemblable à la
faim organisée par la communauté
d'agglomération et le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines le concours a réuni huit
classes de 6e et de 5e avec le conteur
les élèves ont travaillé leur menteries
lors d'ateliers dans chaque collège
ça leur permet de développer leur
imaginaire de développer aussi leur
vocabulaire viaur apprendre à se
produire sur scène
donc c'est vrai que ça ressemble un
petit peu à du théâtre et du coup c'est
vrai qu'ils ont ils ont tout de suite
accroché en fait dès qu'on a commencé
les ateliers
faire durer l'histoire donné des détails
la rendre vivante un seul élève par
classe et est sélectionnée pour monter
sur scène et participer à cette grande
finale
ce jour là ils sont aussi jugés sur
l'originalité de l'histoire le
vocabulaire ou encore l'attitude il
applique les bonnes conseil du comté
décrit drelon de parler lentement et
voilà par exemple de faire des gestes de
de bien respirer pour peut avoir le trac
au tessin baptiste est le grand gagnant
de cette édition
ses camarades du collège albert einstein
de magny les hameaux sont tous fiers de
lui
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition nous repartons à
présent sur la croisette sur place pour
radio sensations et pour tv fil 78
depuis lundi nicolas kirillovitch à la
rencontre et des yvelinois et ce soir du
fondateur de la société blackbird c'est
une société de location de véhicules de
luxe avec chauffeur des véhicules
néanmoins écologique
le festival de cannes est forcément une
vitrine exceptionnelle pour les marques
chaque année elles sont plus d'une
vingtaine à s'installer sur la croisette
pour profiter du rayonnement de
l'événement il y a les couturiers les
joaillier qui se battent pour habiller
les stars et les grandes marques
alimentaires qui accueille les people
les journalistes et les festivaliers sur
des plages ou lors de soirées privées
david aime faire est un jeune qui monte
un i l'affairé lui le bon filon pour
faire connaître sa société de voiture
avec chauffeur
a cannes pendant le festival faire appel
aux services d'une voiture avec
chauffeur n'a rien d'exceptionnel
bonjour luxe élégance raffinement
je vous en prie installer vos cannes ses
palmiers ses stars c'est palace pendant
dix jours l'atmosphère est incomparable
c'est très intéressant de voir cannes
brouillé comme ça de deux personnalités
de gens c'est le quotidien de david aime
faire son métier chauffeur privé
ce génie montant de 28 ans a quitté la
région parisienne où ils travaillent
habituellement pour venir vivre le
festival de l'intérieur c'est pour une
expérience parce que paris c'est très
calme avec les ponts du mois de mai
parce que quitte est dans des bouchons
autant être vue que l'opportunité se
proposait dans des bouchons sur le bord
de mer et pour gagner de l'argent c'est
c'est calme à paris ça bouge beaucoup
pendant le festival donc on a tout à
gagner à descendre à descendre pendant
la période en tout cas travailler sur
table et financièrement c'est plutôt
avantageux puisqu'il fait deux à trois
fois plus de chiffre d'affaires qu'à
paris s'il travaille pour über et
chauffeurs privés david aime faire est
aussi le patron de sa propre entreprise
en fin de journée après quelques années
dans la vente et des études d'ingénieur
du son au troisième set rap face à la
précarité du milieu d'intermittents du
spectacle
david décide de se reconvertir et de
créer sa propre société
quand j'étais en période de
de chômage j'ai fait j'ai eu des
expériences en tant que chauffeur pour
des événements comme comme roland garros
les masters de bercy et donc qui m'ont
qui m'ont donné envie de ne pas faire ça
uniquement en intérim pour des pour des
événements ponctuels mais faire ça en
permanence et donc j'ai créé ma société
à partir de là j'ai lancé la création de
la société et david s'est investi à 100%
dans la création de sa société
transporte 6500 euros pour l'entreprise
puis 80000 euros pour acheter sa berline
blackburn est né mi décembre 2014 et
david ne regrette pas son choix
ça se passe très bien je pensais que ça
allait être plus
répétitif ou plus mais en fait non c'est
très intéressant humainement de
rencontrer beaucoup de monde a très bon
moi j'aime beaucoup conduire donc ça
facilite aussi les choses j'aime
beaucoup le service à la personne donc
le mélange des trois fait que que c'est
un métier qui me plaît énormément et qui
se passe pour l'instant très bien sur
les six premiers mois en tout cas c'est
que du bonheur de se lever le matin pour
aller travailler
david est au volant d'une voiture
écologique une voiture électrique de la
marque tesla
si l'investissement a été conséquent à
l'achat le véhicule s'avère rentable sur
le long terme puisque un chauffeur roule
en moyenne 70 mille kilomètres par an la
seule contrainte trouver des bandes pour
se recharger pendant le festival david
est obligé d'aller jusqu'à fréjus à 45e
minute de cannes pour recharger sa
voiture mais avantage tout de même c'est
gratuit entre 20 et 45 minutes
on recharge suffisamment de batteries
pour atteindre un prochain super charger
et donc faire en faisant des sauts de
puce voyager gratuitement à travers
l'europe
et sinon en région parisienne on peut se
brancher sur toutes les bornes autolib
on peut se brancher sur des chargeurs
nissan dans les parkings dans les
centres commerciaux il ya souvent
maintenant des chargeurs qui sont à part
autolib en règle générale tous gratuits
pour l'instant l'entreprise de david ne
dispose que d'une seule voiture mais ils
envisagent d'en acquérir une deuxième
dans l'optique de proposer des offres de
transport sur mesure à sa clientèle
demain vendredi dernier volet de ce
dossier consacré à cannes et focus sur
le festival des juniors le luxe toujours
mais à versailles avec hier soir au
château une soirée est organisée pour
les 300 ans de martel célèbre marque de
cognac charente s 300 en trois cents
invités vedettes de la soirée est
également ambassadrice de la marque
l'actrice diane kruger et puis juste
avant le repas composé notamment de
rouleaux de homard d'un melba d'huîtres
et de saint jacques aux algues ou encore
d'une soupe au pain grillé à la trophée
à la truffe c'est la patrouille de
france ensuite l avant par avant qui
s'est invitée pour l'apéritif c'est la
fin de ce journal rendez vous vendredi
pour l essentiel du jour le résumé de la
semaine replay et des précédentes
éditions de nos reportages sur notre
site internet dès à présent à demain
[Musique]